your questions I've asked you two
questions should a mass stay in power
and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that on TV on Radio and on your
smartphone this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight on pebg on Sor Pakistan votes
in contentious elections overshadowed by
terror attack and the jailing of former
prime minister Imran Khan or talk
exclusively to imran's
Sister professional footballer Jack
Diamond says his career was derailed by
a false allegation of rape he was
cleared and he now tells me his story
for the first time and we'll debate
whether anonymity the men accused of
rape should now be
mandatory and it's the British
Countryside racist a damning report to
British MPS says our green and pleasant
land is a colonial hellscape will debate
whether they're the
problem from the news building in London
this is pi Morgan
uncensored good evening from London
welcome to Pi Morgan un sensive the
Great British Countryside has long been
fabled as a green and pleasant land
Rolling Hills hearty forests deep
valleys beneath a blanket of morning fog
it's a jewel in the crown of our Magical
Kingdom a place of Peace reflection and
vitality open to us all at least that's
what we were raised to believe but it
turns out we've all been laboring under
a massive misapprehension this green and
pleasant land is in fact a hot bed of
white racism and in influential Lobby of
wildlife Charities has given evidence to
parliamentary committee on race and
community and the results make for
disturbing reading the British
Countryside is apparently a racist and
Colonial white space minorities face
structural exponential and cultural
opposition to accessing green spaces
that evidence says that cultural
barriers reflect that in the UK it is
white British cultural values that have
been embedded into the design and
management of green spaces and into
societies expectations of how people
should be engaging with them really do
anybody actually believe that Tosh
seriously firstly white British cultural
values should probably be expected in
the country where most people are
British and white but those values don't
automatically mean racism and it's
frankly dangerous to keep telling people
otherwise without actual evidence if the
point of this report is to say that
minorities are less likely to live in
areas with access to the plentiful
Countryside and we should try and
improve that than it should say that
pontificating relentlessly that
everybody in everything is
racist or a victim of racism that to me
seems the real problem here and frankly
unlike the British Countryside it also
strikes me as
racist I'm now joined by talk Tov
International editor Isabelle oakshaw
and the associate editor of the mirror
Kevin Maguire
Kevin can you try and construct a
plausible explanation for why I'm
reading headlines at our Great British
Countryside the rolling Fields where I
grew up in leafy East Sussex is actually
a hot bed of colonial white supremacism
no but thank you fin it's even broken
Maguire even broken Maguire but a lot of
stately homes were built on the back of
slavery and exploitation
right there is there is a problem and I
think it needs to be addressed and you
touched on it there that if black
Britains Asian Britains Britains of
color are less likely to go into the
country side why is that because the
country side's fantastic you'd want
everybody to enjoy and not everybody is
enjoying it it's not because they're
going to be attacked on site by a bunch
of races it's complete nonsense you're
more likely to get that in in an urban
area actually but it's demographics I
mean half of all black people live in
London and it's takes absolutely ages to
get into the country
of about 1500 people I think there were
just two or three people who weren't
white when I grew up right and then an
Indian family bought the local
restaurant and suddenly we had 40 to 50
Indian people moved in and actually they
were transformative for the village in a
very um but nobody was racist about the
fact that most people in the village
were white look there will be some and I
don't think people came to the V thought
wow you're a bunch of nasty races there
there will be some races
will be in a town or a city those people
exist uh everywhere but no I kind of
think reports like this don't help they
don't help because they get people's
backs up and make them oppose the report
and feel less like isab the idea that
there's been a whole committee that's
looks into this right to try and prove
the countryside is racist if a headline
when it appears rather than have people
take it seriously makes people guffle
with incredulity at how stupid it sounds
they shouldn't be doing committees to do
this well I searched in vain for the
recommendations of how to make the
countryside less racist and funny enough
there aren't any because this is just
some evidence to a committee that has to
produce the recommendations itself I
mean we could talk about housing and
access to housing in nicer parts of
Britain and that would be a very
sensible conversation to have I mean
there's part to me that almost SS well
hooray is this you know the the race
equality Brigade is this the best they
can come up with because we've made so
many so much progress in so many other
areas of genuine racism that actually
there's not much left to go for I think
I'll end this particular part of the
pack by saying if if even Kevin Maguire
can't defend it you know the woke
Brigade have gone simply too far beyond
beyond the pale racism still exists and
people still discrimination no one
however however I'm not saying the
countryside let me remind everybody we
are one of the most m Multicultural
tolerant countries on God's Earth the
idea that everything about Britain is
racist and we're all a bunch of racist
is not true even if Mega marle tells you
it is um stay with me I want you to
comment on this Pakistan headed to the
polls today in a crucial election one
man not on the ballot however is the
former prime minister and Cricket Legend
Imran Khan he's currently imprisoned on
multiple convictions as is his wife and
he's been banned from taking part in the
election well I spoke to his sister Al
Lima who's just visited her brother in
prison and I began by asking her how
he's doing he's keeping really well uh
since well he's been in prison since six
months now and uh from the beginning he
said he feels he's come to a retreat
where he's had he has time to read books
he's been studying the
Quran uh so he's quite organized with
his exercise and reading books in fact I
think one of our most stressful
situations occurs when we take books for
him and he's yesterday he said he's read
all of them what kind of conditions is
he living in in prison it's a very tiny
cell he doesn't really talk about it
much and his one meal is in the
afternoon uh because in the evening they
lock the cell when they close down at se
6:30 or 7:00 he says it's so cold that
they get into their blanket or their do
way it's a quilt so he says you can't
come out after that so it's really cold
just in the last week alone just to put
people who are not aware of what's been
going on uh perhaps outside of of
Pakistan last Tuesday Imam was jailed
for 10 years for leaking classified
documents last Wednesday he and his wife
Bushra were convicted of profiting from
State gifts and given 14-year sentences
they were also both banned from holding
political office for 10 years is um and
then on Saturday a Court ruled that
Imran and Bushra would get another seven
years for avoiding their marriage this
was a case brought by butcher's
ex-husband um saying that it was unislim
and illegal so you you put all this
together and there's a concerted effort
clearly to incarcerate Imran for a very
long period of time and and indeed his
wife how do you feel about that as his
sister well the only Advantage we've had
is we were able to meet him in jail
during uh Court proceedings they allow
five family members in it's not Imran
Khan who's scared VI it is the people
who've incarcerated him who are really
worried and they're not worried from him
because he's incarcerated what they're
worried about is his following there are
two young men who have been very vocal
on their support and that's iman's Sons
uh sullon and cim who tweeted a picture
um of them both holding a PTI colored
Pakistani flag ahead of the election
saying tomorrow this was on the 7th it's
a huge day for Pakistan your vote is
important as soon as you're able to
please post a photo or video saying I
voted PTI with a hasht vote PTI to show
your support uh Pakistan zindabad I know
everyone is very close with his sons how
often is he able to to talk to them is
he allowed to make phone calls maybe
he's spoken about four times in the past
six months that's terrible the normal
prisoners are allowed to speak to their
families every weekend like on a
Saturday which is a normal prisoner in
in jail but not him this comes you know
only just over a year after there was an
assassination attempt on your brother I
spoke to him shortly after that and he
was typical Iman you know dusting
himself down getting on with it not
going to be deterred but he kind of felt
that one day this might you know
somebody might be successful and and
kill him as his sister how do you how do
you feel about the fact that he's become
such a Target to extremists who want to
kill him there's no extremist killing
him that was how they wanted to Stage it
maybe we were worried about his safety
in jail like is he safe in jail will
they poison him so there's always a
concern do you believe the Imam will be
able to get out of prison through
various channels we've received offers
that if you uh agree to leave the
country or if you remained silent for a
couple of years all the 20 202 cases
will magically disappear I would IM
would he ever take a deal like that and
leave Pakistan or not he he won't take
any such deal he hasn't six months
that's what that's why these sentences
are taking you know that's why they
giving such ridiculous sentences rather
like Iman himself you're very flagma
about what is going on it would be
something that would crush many families
but you're clearly made of tough stuff
um I mean does he have a message for the
world if they're watching this interview
his message was very clear he said the
polling agents have to guard the votes
that people are casting it is the it is
the whole thing is about protecting the
vote of the people when you referenced
that you were concerned about him being
potentially poisoned in prison is that a
fear that Imran has and is there
anything you can do to to protect him
from that
happening only Allah can protect him in
jail right now I've got to leave it
there thank you for joining me please
when you speak to inran next please send
him my very best tell him I'm thinking
of him I hope that this all resolves in
a in the proper way for you and that he
gets proper justice but I thank you for
joining me thank you very much thank you
P thank you for having me quite a family
you can watch the full interview with
Imran khar's sister Al Lima on our
YouTube channel now and it's a
fascinating watch just Kevin re I mean
Pakistan politics is just so riddled
with Mayhem and Corruption it is
political violence corruption as you say
extremist groups we've had
assassinations we've had coups we' had a
prime minister former prime minister
deposed being hanged and it stinks and
it's rather dispiriting there hasn't
been a louder and greater International
outcry at what's happening now because
the Army rules the roost in Pakistan and
the early indications are that Imran
Khan's party PTI are doing very well but
of course that might trigger Isabelle a
reaction from the military there might
be some move to to stop this happening I
think it's tragic what is happening in
Pakistan because it is a country with
enormous potential and you know the
perception the international perception
of these elections is that they will not
be free and fair and I think that is
such a shame I don't think that Imran
Khan is necessarily the Martyr that
people think he is the reason that he
lost power was because of the way well
long series of events but essentially
shortly after Putin invaded Ukraine
Imran Khan saw fit to go and meet Putin
within about 24 48 hours this is a
politician who was gravitating in all
the wrong directions as far as we in the
west are concerned building alliances
with Russia Iran with China not going in
the right direction but does that mean
he shouldn't have free and fair Justice
no of course it doesn't and and if you
continue to block someone out
unfortunately it can be
counterpredictive
yeah he's open to a lot of political
criticism and making I would say bad
decisions he wanted to dissolve
parliament but never nevertheless it
that really feels as if he's being
denied I don't think there any up
there's no doubt he's being fitted up
and it's I mean he is also guilty of
things and we know he leaked State
secrets and no State just tolerates that
but I think it's it's a very complex
situation he was nearly killed you know
and sister very concerned that he they
may he never had to go into politics
I'll give him that you know and it's
very very we're we're talking about one
of the world's biggest democracies with
240 million people armed with Imam we
were talking about one of the most
iconic Sportsmen yeah you know I mean
when he was he was a cricet legend
beloved by millions and it's failed to
protect him yeah um just want to quickly
mention this announcement by rishy sunak
that protesters who wear masks uh at
protest could could face arrest up to a
month in jail and A1 1,000 fine um human
rights campaigners say it's pandering
the culture War nonsense Kevin I've
never been a fan of people wearing masks
although we were all mandated and
legally required to wear face masks at
times during covid and I think there you
there were reasons some people wearing
religious reasons some uh some women
well laws really existed around this
anyway but hopefully the police will be
sensitive somebody turns up in a
Spiderman Mas happens for example if you
have people testing outside the Chinese
Embassy who are maybe Chinese dissident
or whatever it may be who want to wear a
mask to protect their identity from the
Chinese exacting retribution I mean in
that scenario that is a protest get and
if they're weing masks are we really
going to have people like that arrested
I get that and that is in the category
of difficult cases but I think as a
general rule I do not like the spectacle
of lots and lots of masked people
turning up on protests because quite
simply it complicates the police's
efforts to make sure that those who are
supporting terrorism can be identif they
are normally a small minority when you
see
demonstrations why why are they wearing
those
mask protest yes if you're behaving
peacefully I don't see a problem if
you're going to go rampaging what's the
point of being on a mask if you're not
prepared to stand up and be counted the
whole point of being on a mask I am no
but the legitimate legitimate concern
peers raises about China you might have
family
I don't we can set our rules here in in
the UK according to what China might do
I think we should we should be we
somebody may want to wear a m to avoid
being detective this week as richy sunak
who's not having the best of weeks and
there is a meme doing the rounds now
based around this bizarre Tory promo
video Let's Take a Look flip chart hi I
wanted to talk to you a little bit about
what's going on in the economy and the
plan that we're working towards but
before then I wanted to take you back to
the context that we found ourselves in
we all remember Co and the enormous
impact it had on all of us and because
of that we did a lot of things to get
the country through Co like supporting
the NHS vaccine program Furlow those
things cost around 400 billion with all
the other support we provided I mean
he's he's not I mean he's just a bit
robotic isn't it it's so infantile does
he I mean it's so P well it has prompted
a load of memes let's take a look at
some of these cuz they are very funny
look I quit the first one what's the
second
one next
one here we
[Laughter]
are internet's be full of this help me
funny yeah what and then the last
one oh that is the last one help me yeah
well it probably sums it up he needs a
bit of help doesn't he well think he
does it goes wrong but he's been
compared to David Brent in the office
the the very awkward manager I think
David Brent could sue for being compared
to rishy
sunak uh thank you guys uh good to see
you really appreciate it on sensor next
last month footballer Jack Diamond was
found not guilty of rape charges but in
an exclusive interview with me he says
his life is still ruined and he wants
change that comes
[Music]
next hey good morning to you thanks for
joining us you're with talk TV on TV on
radio online and we're on your smart
speaking good morning Rosie good morning
Nick we're here in torth for you to find
out exactly why some people are
traveling halfway around the world and
queuing for hours for one of these The
Humble British
potato a woman can become a man and a
man can become a woman and if you think
that you're certifiably
insane it's not in Labor's DNA to get
tough on immigration they don't feel it
they don't sense
it this concept that actually kids
wouldn't carry KN if they could go and
play Tiddly Winks at the you know the
corner of the street or whatever I think
it's a
nonsense she was basically saying that
if I don't leave then she's going to
seize my equipment and everyone around
was just
outraged a crossbow a hatchet multiple
crossbows multiple crossbows yeah
crossbows is what it says on the Press
crossbows and the hat car like horse
crossbows like a hatchet and what a
swords and a knife how is that even
technically
possible we go
show it's carry on what just
happened was like brought to you by Ste
KH the mayor of London very rarely meet
anybody that says you know the thing
about London is it's got a great mayor
It's s De KH brilliant
guy nobody is is spending any money
they're not prepared to do it I mean why
is that H quite simple the downturn turn
in the spend is three simple words
Financial fair
play stop creating all of these funny
little factions with their funny little
names the new conservatives the ERG the
common sense research group the red wool
red trouser popcorn I mean popcorn what
what is that absolutely right if I want
to have a Hubba Bubba chalky walkie
Bazooka Joe flavored Vape I can have one
but not according to rishy sunak because
he said no we can't trust you with that
Donald Trump didn't just win he
obliterated this is a guy facing nearly
a hundred criminal charges and yet all
that's done is actually make him more
popular Trump is canny enough to know
that all publicity is good publicity I
don't want a president who's been
impeached if he's able to bamboozle you
or that's the way it goes did my six
months I came back nobody would touch me
I put my head down and persisted and
carried on when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions I've
asked you two questions should a master
stay in power and are they a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV is
the only place where you get the truth
you've done a book on poetry poetry and
music for the many I love poetry we can
agree on
that
[Music]
welcome back to uncensored well
professional footballer Jack Diamond was
found not guilty of rape last month
after a harrowing a 2-year ORD deal that
derailed his promising career and nearly
ruined his life the 23-year-old thought
he could resume things and start his
career ref fresh as an innocent man but
it's not turning out to be quite that
straightforward I sat down with Jack
earlier for exclusive one-on-one
interview his first one he's
given Well Jack Diamond thank you for
for coming down to do this interview
it's the first interview you've done
since you were cleared um you're still a
professional footballer yeah but you've
had to live for years now with the smear
of being an accused rapist I mean first
of all how do you feel that it's it's
over yeah um I'm obviously glad that
it's over but you still had to endure
what I had to endure so I mean I'm
obviously glad that I can talk about it
now but it's it's not it's not a breath
of relief like everyone thinks it will
be take me back to to really what
happened here you connect with this
woman on Tinder yeah which is for those
who don't know it's a dating app it's
very popular and you start seeing each
other how would you categorize a
relationship yeah like as we started
obviously I was young this is 2 years
years ago as well so how old were you at
the time I was 19 when I first met her
so and how old was she she was 192 as
well and you had a sexual relationship
for I think a year right yeah yeah how
often would you see each other every two
three weeks casual nothing like planned
wasn't too serious um but was there
anything in that period that gave you
alarm bells or was it perfectly normal I
think at the end there was a bit of
alarm Bell there was an incident that
happened where maybe sh that should like
me a bit more than I liked her and
wanted something a bit more serious um
so that's when I kind of disconnected
for a while but that was like the first
time I kind of came into contact with
her and started speaking her you know
obviously have a relationship let's get
then to the the night that she says that
you raped her it's you've now been
cleared of all uh all charges obviously
what happened well it was nothing out
the ordinary at all that night um the
only thing that didn't obviously happen
was was one of the only times we didn't
have sex um um had you gone out that
night or I'd been out to see cuz my
season had finished so I went to see a
few friends um just locally and then I
got back at about 10 half 10 and then as
I usually would or she would like on a
Saturday night or whatever um would give
each other a text see what she was doing
and then she end up coming around uh to
your place to my place at about 20
minutes after I called her so and what
happened well the she just came in um
just let herself in because obviously
I've been seen her for so long now was
very informal so she just came and let
herself in came upstairs and then she's
undressed and got on my bed um and then
just normal just ch chatting a little
bit and then start kissing touching
everything like this um which he says
was all consensual and then I've I've
like initiated initiated like doing
stuff she's also done that just like um
like touching and stuff like that um and
and then she's basically got on top of
us to try and initiate sex and I've said
I I don't want to have sex basically you
weren't in the mood I wasn't I wasn't in
the mood like I just just got home was
very late so then she just um turned
over in kind of like a strop as I
thought but obviously I kind of brush it
off as like oh she just in a bit of a
huff so then I have initiated sex back
and we're just kissing again and uh
she's just said I think the moment's
gone and I was like right okay no
problem got off and then about 30
minutes later she just got up and left
um and said she's went do you want to
support ke for the letter box and lock
the door and everything and I was like
yeah thanks no problem so you felt this
was the end yeah I was just like I
thought she was just in a bit of a huff
she left yeah and she left the keys in
the house through the letter box locked
the door put the keys through the and
she's gone yeah and then what's the next
you hear um about half 8 in the morning
and then obviously the police came the
door to your house yeah um and I didn't
really know what to say and they're like
hi Jack know here you are come we come
in I'm like yeah fine and I still didn't
have a clue just like an incident
happened with a girl last night you know
and I was like just in shock because
obviously I knew exactly what went on
that night you're a professional
footballer at 19 you you're living your
dream yeah earning great money playing
the game you love everything going well
for you and then suddenly you're in a
prison cell yeah and you're being
accused of assaulting this girl yeah you
don't know quite the full scale of the
charges at that stage but you mhm in
those hours what is going through your
head just disbelief and obviously they
said was it was digital penetration
that's what they said I was going to
arested for um and I didn't know what
that was you know what I mean I was 20
19 20 21 at the time I didn't have a
clue I didn't have a clue what it was so
I'm saying what's this what does that
mean then they're briefly telling us um
saying then need swap my fingers and I'm
thinking what the hell so then they'
took us to the the cells and I'm just
sat there thinking I don't know what I
think that was the scariest thing
because I didn't know what what had been
said what she said terrified yeah well
because I'm sitting there thinking if I
can get arrested for something that I
don't even know what's what's being said
I just knew whatever is going to be said
is going to be false did you have a
lawyer yeah I got just a bared that the
called and when he came then he kind of
like told us everything that happened
and uh she hadn't give a statement so I
was like which she what you mean she's
not give a statement uh So what had
happened is she basically said a passing
comment to our mate like saying know he
tried to force himself on his or or
something along them lines um and then I
M basically told her father and our
dad's hit the roof as you would um and
like it's it's unbeli spiral out of
control and then at that point well even
in the tape just to say oh well she
doesn't want to bring the police she say
her dad no no don't call the police and
everything but as a father as you word
that's the first thing you do is call
the police what about your family how
did they react oh well it was it was
tough because my family thought I was in
the lead they thought I was out and then
my mom's text my phone obviously asking
us uh where you how are you doing
obviously she's not heard from us for
like six six seven hours um so then I
told her I was like uh L I'm just got
out police station um she must have been
horrified yeah I think she just hung the
phone so when was the moment you
realized you were going to be
charged so I didn't hear anything for
about a year uh and then kind of just
thought oh it's went away like
ridiculous I went on loan but then I've
kind of just forgot about it slowly
thinking all it's went
away um and then I think I'd came home
midweek for some reason I think I was
shopping with my mom at the time and
then I got the call off the solicitor um
who obviously with last time and I've
not heard for a year so I was thinking
oh my God like my heart just sunk so
I've answered the phone and I just went
listen out with my parents at the moment
can I call you when I return home he's
like
yeah um and then I'm just obviously
praying for the best cuz I know that
this is obviously going to be an answer
uh so I've dropped my man back off
because I was like good or bad news I
don't want to be there when I don't want
her to be there when I here so um I went
back to my house and then rang him back
uh and he just said I think you might
want to sit down um you've been charged
of rape and digital penetration and
obviously that was the first time I'd
even heard about the rape so assum what
did that word do to
you I just couldn't understand it it was
just like at that point it was just like
everything's done um like football
wasn't in my
head like friends W it was just like my
family like I was just thinking this is
going to change everything of course so
like at that point I just thought well
football is never happening do you know
what I mean that's it the end of your
career hey very good morning to you
thanks for joining us you're with talk
TV on TV on radio online and we're on
your smart speaking good morning Rosie
good morning Nick we're here in
turnworth for you to find out exactly
why some people are traveling halfway
around the world and queuing for hours
for one of these The Humble British
potato a woman can become a man and a
man can become a woman and if you think
that you're certifiably
insane it's not in Labor's DNA to get
tough on immigration they don't feel it
they don't
sense this concept that actually kids
wouldn't carry knives if they could go
and play Tiddly Winks at the you know
the corner of a street or whatever I
think it's a
nonsense she was basically saying that
if I don't leave then she's going to
seize my equipment and everyone around
was just
outraged a crossbow a hatchet multiple
crossbows multiple crossbows yeah
crossbows is what it says on the Press
crossbows and a carry on a crossbows and
a hatchet and what a swords and the
knife how is that even technically
possible we
go it's carry on what just
happen was like brought to you by St KH
the mayor of London rarely meet anybody
that says you know the thing about
London is it's got a great mayor it's a
deep K brilliant
guy nobody is is spending any money
they're not prepared to do it I mean why
is that H quite simple the downturn in
the spend is three simple words
Financial fair
play stop creating all of these funny
little factions with their funny little
names the new conservatives the ERG the
common sense research group the red wool
red trouser popcorn I mean popcorn what
what is is that absolutely right if I
want to have a Hubba Bubba chalky walkie
Bazooka Joe flavored Vape I can have one
but not according to rishy sunak because
he said no we can't trust you with
that this is talk
[Music]
TV and when did your name get out in
relation to that charge two days later
two no a day later and was all the
papers yeah and that when you're named
next to the word rape is about as bad as
yeah it can get for you right you're a
young man and this is what everyone is
reading about you yeah what was that
like to have to read headlines about
yourself like that uh it was scary
because
obviously I knew what what had went on
what had happened and then I'm sat there
kind of defenseless can't say listen I
didn't do this you know what I mean I
can't just pop up everywhere and go
every new story I'm innocent I'm
innocent because you're not really
allowed to you're just what was the
reaction from people in the streets and
stuff um I didn't really leave the house
for about a week or two um I'd went cuz
I was at home at the time I live by
myself the the moved my friend the club
and moved my friend out the house um and
they suspended you right yeah so a day
later I got suspended and how long was
it until the the trial um a yeah so you
basically this is 2 years of your life
you've had to live with this obviously
when the police released the statement
they've named us they've put me
addressing it big picture of me with man
rapes well the name just said Jack
Diamond with uh and then I'm reading
that and I'm thinking how how can they
do this do you know what I mean um and
she remains Anonymous yeah at tu's day I
mean you can't say who it is the police
are supposed to be there to protect us
though putting that next to my name with
me addressing
first thing I'm thinking is someone's
going to come to my house or someone's
going to try and do something did you
get any bad incidents like that no but
like you're thinking about it all the
time think about it eventually at the
end of the the trial how long did it
last the trial it was about five days I
believe yeah and at the end of it you
had a jury yeah and you're looking at
these 12 people and they're going to
decide yeah the rest of your life yeah
and when they give the verdict what is
that
feeling like when you're waiting as you
see them about to deliver the
verdict uh well it was a bit crazy
because we thought it was going to be a
day cuz it was only about an hour left
of the the actual Court time so we've
went to the shop to be like oh it's
probably going to be another day so I'm
thinking I'm have to wait another day
for all this um and then I think we've
literally got the bottom of the stairs
and my dad's texted saying the clerk's
looking for you uh so like my bar is
panicking thinking oh
this is it they've like they can't have
done it this quick
um and then came in and I was just
looking forward I didn't want to look at
them didn't want to look at anyone and
obviously because it was two counts I
heard the first not guilty and then I
heard the second and
then yeah it just it was crazy but the
feeling
of like relief lasted I would say about
two minutes really
yeah and then because then after I just
think all of this for seven minutes all
of this for this to be this quick I was
like how ridiculous were you emotional
in that yeah cried yeah I think my whole
family did my bar cried what was your
bar cried really yeah that's unusual
yeah well GTH daisher he uh he worked
quite close he saw us this whole time um
yeah she cried you're barass yeah
because when I came out of when I first
got charged OB I went away for a bit um
he looked after us all this time and
kind of prepped us did had a real Bond
yeah how was your mom when he got
cleared yeah she was just in tears my
sister and me D every every single
person you know what I mean
and I think that was the the hardest
thing as well because obviously I told
her this whole time I was like I was
putting on trying to be confident it's
going to be all right it's going to be
all right more for my family because I
think if they've saw me struggling uh
and upset but I think it was just I was
happy for them as well how long did the
jury take to do deliberate seven minutes
seven minutes yeah so you went through
over two years of hell and it took a
jury just seven minutes to clear you
yeah which is an emphatic repudiation of
what this woman had been claiming they
just didn't believe what she was saying
but you were dragged through this hell
for so long yeah and even as you sit
here now a cleared man you know for the
rest of your life it'll have Jack
diamond and the word rape and you'll be
forever associated with that yeah when
you play football you're going to play
well I don't know what's been happening
what's been happening with the
opposition fans do they ear abuse say I
did the other the other day I came off
uh came off injured TR to walk past the
hall away that was your first game back
yeah um so I got who were you playing
you were playing for carile against yeah
late in Orient and what happened uh well
I've came off injured um and I was
obviously at that point I was annoyed
anyways um but then I've had to walk
around the whole pitch cuz you can't
just walk off for quickness and
obviously I got the chance straight away
as I'm walking past them and I was just
thinking what was the chance um she said
no diamond she said no um really yeah
but I was I'm kind of expecting this um
it's still horrible yeah and you
probably going to get that from away
fans everywhere how are you going to
deal with that
mentally I think just with everything
this whole time it's just been something
positive will come out of it or there's
something I can do to either use it to
fight fuelers um just trying not to
react do you know what I mean I think
this whole time has been mentally like
strong for us because I've obviously had
paper's name is basically called as the
worst thing in the world um my family's
being obviously associate like I've not
just been the one struggling through it
like they took a few weeks off work
because they were embarrassed right
everybody of course your case is similar
to a guy interview called Jordan trenro
he was very young a complete fantasist
invented story similar about him um and
it ruined his life certainly for a long
time um and it Sparks again this whole
debate as we were saying about the
anonymity issue how do you feel I mean
do you feel after what you've been
through and indeed what Jord went
through do do you think that it's unfair
that only the man who's accused gets
named do you think it would be right to
change the law so that if you bring an
allegation of rap both sides get named
or both sides are Anonymous which do you
think would be fair I think both sides
should definitely be an anonymous until
a point of conviction of course
because because if you had been if the
law did that the papers couldn't have
mentioned your name nobody would have
known it was you you would have been
acquitted and no one would have known
anything about it and you would sit here
you wouldn't be sitting here you
wouldn't need to be MH cu no one would
know it was you yeah of course and I
think I probably wouldn't be suspended
either what are your feelings towards
the the girl who made these allegations
against I wouldn't say it's hatred I
think it's I'm embarrassed for her um do
you think it all got out of control that
once her father found out and reacted
the way he did did and the police got
involved she felt she just couldn't go
back on it yeah well the can't like the
police push it so much um CPS push it so
much to try and get these conviction
rates the one one Higher how's it
affected you with other girls now I mean
have youve been able to have a
relationship since no uh well obviously
because this has been going on two years
as well um obviously it was known for a
year um but then even when it wasn't
known I wasn't publicly have you had any
sexual relationship at all since no and
how
long about a year a year now since it's
been going on um since obviously I've
been named I'm not since you were
charged and named yeah um so a young man
and you you you just don't want to take
the the
chance that's that's terrible it's it's
crazy because even my friends obviously
my close friends now when I tell them
how ridiculous and how how scary it can
actually be because it can be one word
against the other and then you go on to
court Jack uh it's good to meet you and
thank you for being so honest with the
interview I think it's awful what
happened to you I think it is something
that you need to try and put it behind
you now if you can it's very difficult I
know that you'll be reminded of it every
match you play by I'm sure opposition
fans but in a way I think what you said
about having it fuel you may make you an
even better player definitely you never
know what doesn't break you makes you
stronger as they're saying right and I
want to wish you all the very best thank
you very unless you play Arsenal and in
that eventuality I want you to lose no
otherwise I hope you win cheers good
luck to you thank you very
much hey very good morning to you thanks
for joining us you're with talk TV on TV
on radio online and we're on your smart
speaking good morning Rosy good morning
Nick we're here in Tamworth for you to
find out exactly why some people are
traveling Halfway Around the World and
queuing for hours for one of these The
Humble British
potato a woman can become a man and a
man can become a woman and if you think
that you're certifiably
insane it's not in Labor's DNA to get
tough on immigration they don't feel it
they don't sense
it this concept that actually kids
wouldn't carry knives if they could go
and play Tiddly Winks at the you know
the corner of the street or whatever I
think it's
nonsense she was basically saying that
if I don't leave then she's going to
seize my equipment and everyone around
was just
outraged a crossbow a hatchet multiple
crossbows multiple crossbows yeah
crossbows is what it says on the pr
crossbows and a carry on a crossbows and
a hatchet and what a sword and a knife
how is that even technically
possible we going on this show it's
carry on what just
happened
was like brought to you by sque KH the
mayor of London very rarely meet anybody
that says you know the thing about
London is it's got a great mayor sque
Brant
guy nobody is is spending any money
they're not prepared to do it I mean why
is that H quite simple the downturn in
the spend is three simple words
Financial fair
play stop creating these funny little
factions with their funny little names
the new conservatives the ERG the common
sense research group The red wool red
trouser popcorn I mean popcorn what what
is that absolutely right if I want to
have a Hubba Bubba chalky walkie Bazooka
Joe flavored Vape I can have one but not
according to rishy sunak because he said
no we can't trust you with that Donald
Trump didn't just win he obliterated
this is a guy facing nearly a 100
criminal charges and yet all that's done
is actually make him more popular Trump
is canning enough to know that all
publicity is good publicity I don't want
a president who's been impeached if he's
able to bamboozle you or that's the wake
up but did my 6 months I came back
nobody would touch me I put my head down
I persisted I carry down when I say I am
God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions I've
asked you two questions should a mass
stay in power and are they a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV
it's the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
[Music]
that welcome back to uncensor where I've
reassembled some of my pack and brought
in some new members to talk through the
issues raised by that interview with the
footballer Jack Diamond I want to focus
on this exchange do do you think that
it's unfair that only the man who's
accused gets named do you think it would
be right to change the law I think both
sides should definitely be an anonymous
until a point of conviction of course
because because if you had been if the
law did that the papers couldn't have
mentioned your name nobody would have
known it was you you would have been
acquitted and no one would have known
anything about it well here to discuss
that is my p as I said the YouTuber and
commentator PE Davis associate editor of
the mirror Kevin Maguire um Kevin it's
complicated this issue I don't pretend
it isn't I've interviewed a few people
who been this position but listening to
this this guy he's a young man he was 19
when this first happened he's met
someone on Tinder which is the way a lot
of young people meet other sexual
partners these days but for a year
they're seeing you each other and then
according to him and he's been cleared
and so I think his his version is the
credible one he says they just had a
slight disagreement she was annoyed that
he didn't want to have sex with her she
left in a bit of a mood and the next
thing the police turn up yeah and his
life is completely upended you're a
Sunderland fan actually yeah he played
for us a couple of uh couple of dozen
times he On LAN a lot I think he's at
car Isle now as he tries to you know
rebuild his uh his career what about his
argument
that why should she who it turned out
made false allegations very serious ones
why should she remain anonymous to the
point we can't say who it is but he has
been named immediately that he was
charged splashed all over the papers
splashed all over the television
suspended by his Club lost his job for
the interim period until the trial then
gets cleared in seven minutes by the
jury you clearly are having none of this
why why should he be forever tained with
it appears in the in these cases because
the jury finds you not guilty doesn't
mean the person has has lied that's not
the automatic side it's got to be a case
beyond all Reasonable Doubt Me didn't
believe now I I have huge sympathy for
him through what he's gone through but I
don't accept uh cripping private Justice
where you don't know for instance people
are arrested now and you can't report
you can't know they've been arrested and
they're being
investigated his point his is in he in
we've got to accept he's innocent now
he's he's gone through a terrible time
that I get why would a woman not do it
again if there's no consequence for her
doing it look I mean we're rewarding
we're rewarding bad behavior no no if if
the police the crown prosecution service
believe you deliberately made up
allegations you will be prosecuted and
there are cases and then those women are
named but p a jury of 12 people took
seven minutes I mean some juries take
seven days days they took seven minutes
to find for this young man I have to say
when I interviewed him I found him
extremely uh he was very polite
respectful I believed him uh and I felt
so sorry for it's could to be one of my
sons I was like he's been through utter
hell and yet nobody knows anything about
who this girl is I'm not saying for a
moment she should be named and
shamed I think she should well I'm sure
I mean some women probably do feel that
actually I mean I just I think if we
keep alive o women to weaponize the
justice system against men why would
they stop why why would they stop there
there has to be there has to be some
consequence for women that ruin men's
careers prosecutions successful
prosecutions where rap is reported is
incredibly low there was a huge problem
now I'm setting aside the the the
Diamond Case for a moment it is
incredibly difficult to prove and there
are very few prosecutions now you can
just say all women are just making
complaints no they are not in a way
we're having in a way we're having a
slightly different debate we'll come to
that on the specifics po his argument is
why should he be named until or if he's
convicted that he wants anonymity for
both sides the accuser and the accused
until there is a verdict I think it
should either be they're both public or
they're both private I agree I agree I I
don't think it's fair that you can
accuse someone of a crime you completely
ruin their career and there's no
consequence for you what the police
through the police will say that when
get some of these cases quite a few
probably that the naming of the alleged
rapist often leads many other victims to
come forward and we've seen that happen
there's no doubt that can be a key
factor in persuading other victims
suddenly you have a mass serial rapist
so that's the argument from the police
as to why they want to name the people
who are accused because they want to
encourage potential other victims and I
understand the thought process but I I
just see nowadays I mean nobody believes
anyone that comes forward this with this
kind of thing because so many women
abuse the system so what they're doing
now it's not working and I I'm not sure
what exactly the solution is but I think
what he's proposing is more fair than
what they have right now it does seem
the it does seem the least you can do
frankly I mean I've intered another
young man uh last year you know who
who'd been despicably framed by a
complete fantasist who'd attacked
herself and claimed that he had done it
and so on um and she's in jail now she's
in jail now she was held account and we
know who she is she was Pitch so she did
not have anony
anonymity Point she did get Nam shamed
and and brought account but I interview
I interview men that this happens to all
the time in Family Court this is this is
I I I'm doing a documentary on divorce
and this is really common in family
court it's different than criminal court
but the problem is they changeed the
definition of rape it used to be force
sex now it's sex without consent it
makes it more Broad and it makes it
easier for women to to prosecute in
Diamond the ca yeah the case that needs
to be answered is why the crown
prosecution service took the case of
it's dismissed in seven minutes because
there needs to be to bring a case a
realistic uh Prospect of a conviction
let's bring in Paul arone uh Adan talked
to the contributor and a family lawyer
Paula I mean it really did make me feel
uncomfortable this interview um because
it's the second one like it I've done in
the last few months and both times
you've got young men who were completely
fitted up it seems uh both eventually
clear but will never have their name
properly cleared you know this poor guy
the first game back he plays the fans
are chanting Abus at him about being a
rapist he's going to get that the rest
of his career doesn't seem right why
can't he remain anonymous like all rape
accusers remain anonymous until or if
he's
convicted well we know why that is
because it's not about why we compare
the defender or the defendant forgive me
to the uh potential victim the alleged
victim it's comparing the defendant to
other defendants in cases we don't say
for example to somebody who has been
accused of an attempted murder or
somebody who's been accused of abusing a
child or somebody who's been accused of
armed robbery that they should
automatically get anonymity and of
course those are incredibly serious
allegations as well but you're asking me
about when you accuse someone of
attempting murder we know who's doing
the accusing that they're not given
anonymity it's only in sexual cases like
rape and serious sexual assault that the
accusers retain anonymity throughout the
whole process and his argument is well
why can't that apply to the people being
accused and if they're found guilty then
name and shame them to your heart's
content they should be but if they un
acquitted then nobody would ever know
that they were accused of something they
didn't
do and and PE don't get me wrong it's
not that I don't appreciate the
sensitivity of this of of course I do
but what you're asking the criminal
justice system to do is to essentially
pay lip service to what is a distressing
situation for everybody and I understand
because I'm asking I'm asking he he be
clear I'm not asking for anything he is
asking for a fairer system that gives
anonymity to both sides until there's a
verdict and I think there's a lot of
Merit to that the more of these young
men I interview who are on the receiving
end of fantasists or people who juries
don't believe uh who then have to live
with a stigma for the rest of their
lives the more I'm leaning to thinking
well why don't we just have anonymity on
both sides makes sense so this has been
considered on a number of occasions it
was considered back in the 1970s it was
considered cons back in the 1980s it was
considered even in 2010 with a coalition
government and on each occasion when the
evidence was properly looked at the
decision has always been that actually
it doesn't make a difference in terms of
the outcomes for the defendant but it
absolutely makes a difference in terms
of the outcomes for alleged victims and
whether they are coming forward and I
heard you in the interview of course um
address the issue that we all know that
we have such low reporting figures in
terms of allegations of
rap and that is completely wrong but I
still P I still have a lot of sympathy
with this guy's argument or make it or
make it both public like if if you're
going to accuse someone make it public
why why does one side get to be private
and one public that doesn't make any
sense Kevin yeah look if anything I
would WR i' would row it back like we
have as I say now you can't report if
somebody is arrested you know somebody
can be arrested might be there's a
politician there's an MP who's under
investigation for rape and he's been
arrested he doesn't go to the House of
Commons and we can't name him legally
we're in we're in the wrong world the
very at the very least what this case
should do is lead to a new debate about
this yeah we don't a why a cloak I feel
very sorry for him thank you to both of
you and thank you to Paula well before
we go tonight some news about me and the
show I think it's good news this is
going to be our final regular broadcast
here on television but appears
uncensored is only going to get bigger
the truth is that many millions of you
are watching us on YouTube every day and
across our other digital platforms so
much so that cutting short our big
interviews and debates to squeeze them
into a single hour with commercials no
longer makes any real sense so we're
going to expand what we do we're going
to give you more not less from Monday
February the 19th you can watch us
exclusively on the PE Morgan uncensored
YouTube channel joining more than 2.3
million subscribers across the the world
and that means you can watch us when and
where you want to we're going to go
where the audience is and give the
audience what you want expect the same
big exclusive interviews the same
Fearless debates the same uncensored
opinions and more of them all I'll see
you on the other side but from now with
thanks from my team and me to all of you
watching us here go and find us on the
YouTube channel because you'll find we
are just as un sensive good
[Music]
night
hey very good morning to you thanks for
joining us you're with talk TV on TV on
radio online you're on your smart
speaking good morning Rosie good morning
Nick we're here in torth for you to find
out exactly why some people are
traveling halfway around the world and
queuing for hours for one of these The
Humble British
potato a woman can become a man and a
man can become a woman and if you think
that you're certifiably
insane it's not in Labor's DNA to get
tough on immigration they don't feel it
they don't sense it this concept that
actually kids wouldn't carry knives if
they could go and play Tiddly Winks at
the you know the corner of the street or
whatever I think it's a
nonsense she was basically saying that
if I don't leave then she's going to
seize my equipment and everyone around
was just
outraged a crossbow a hatchet multiple
crossbows multiple crossbow yeah
crossbows is what it says on the Press
crossbows and a carry on a crossbows and
a hatchet and what a sword and a knife
how is that even technically
possible we
go it's carry on what just
happened was like brought to you by S KH
the mayor of London very rarely meet
anybody that says you know the thing
about London is it's got a great mayor
It's s deep C brilliant
guy nobody is is spending any money
they're not prepared to do it I mean why
is that uh quite simple the downturn in
the spend is three simple words
Financial fair
play stop creating all of these funny
little factions with their funny little
names the new conservatives the ERG the
common sense research group the red wool
red trouser popcorn I mean popcorn what
what is that absolutely right if I want
to have a Hubba Bubba chalky walkie
Bazooka Joe flavored Vape I can have one
but not according to toishi sunak
because he said no we can't trust you
with that Donald Trump didn't just win
he obliterated this is a guy facing
nearly a hundred criminal charges and
yet all that's done is actually make him
more popular Trump is canny enough to
know that all publicity is good
publicity I don't want a president who's
been impeached if he's able to bamboozle
you or that's the way it comes did my 6
months I came back nobody would touch me
I put my head down and persisted and
carried on when I say I am God I'm not
joking